terre apprendre à vivre ensemble avec
ses différences depuis deux ans les
scouts de france n'accueille plus
seulement les enfants de confession
catholique il accepte aussi les jeunes
musulmans on les appelle les scouts
mosaïque et durant toute l'année ils
apprennent à se connaître et à
s'apprécier avant de passer quinze jours
de vacances ensemble reportage panier au
vernis silver d'aubin c'est la première
fois qu'elle quitte le cercle de leur
famille noah et hamahoullah sont
musulmanes pratiquantes ex coupe de
france elles appartiennent au groupe
mosaïque rescousse d'un genre nouveau où
chaque religion trouve sa place une
diversité tiens qui était certain faron
ya des gens qui sont comme ça moi aussi
réticents meira je prends à des six ans
qu'il prend
ce camp est un projet conjoint de la
mosquée de la paroisse et d'une
association laïque du 19e arrondissement
de paris un projet difficile à mettre en
oeuvre
même s'il répond à une certaine logique
ces gens vivent là ils ont l'habitude de
se côtoyer
dans la rue dans les écoles
dans d'autres espaces pourquoi pas
ensemble
scout au total neuf enfants dont six
musulmans et rois catholiques vont
apprendre à vivre ensemble
seule différence entre la nourriture et
certains moments de prière mais le reste
du temps les enfants sont mélangés
participent aux mêmes activités au même
groupe de réflexion avec c'est presque
pareil nous vivons sont presque car elle
est jugée depuis toujours un arche de
noé s'enlacer large de nos dépends
communs qui permettent de mieux
comprendre la religion de l'autre
mais pour l'instant la priorité des
enfants est beaucoup plus terre à terre
réussir à installer la tente même si le
ciel ne les aide pas beaucoup que tu
trouves que c'est différent
bah pas trop si à part sont sûrs qu'on
fait dans la religion peut sinon on est
tous coûté on étouffe
on est plusieurs humains quoi sur 100000
scouts de france 200 seulement sont
mosaïque